Using homographies in MATLAB
Let's use the previous MATLAB example to illustrate
some principles around homographies. First
thing I'm going to do is to close these 2
windows and create a new variable called Little
P, which contains the projection of those
world points. Here we go.
So, this is the image plane coordinates of
the points as viewed by that camera up in
the air. The world points P are a set of 3
dimensional coordinates. Note that the Z coordinate
of all of these points is equal to 0. So,
I'm going to create a new vector, just P and
it's just the first 2 rows and it contains
all of the columns. So, this is Q. So, Q are
a set of coordinates of points on the ground
plane that the camera is looking at and P
is a set of pixel coordinates in the view
from that camera up in the air and now that
I have these 2 sets of corresponding 2-D points,
I can compute an homography. I'll just use
the homography function and I parse in the
first set of points, little P and the second
set of points, Q and here is the homography
matrix that's been computed.
Now that I have the homography H, I can apply
it to a single point or 2 multiple points.
To help me with that, there is a toolbox helper
function called 'homtrans' which applies the
homography-H to the set of pixels P. This
is our image plane coordinates and the result
is the set of coordinates of points on the
ground.
We have mapped a set of points in the image
whose coordinates are measured in units of
pixels into a set of points on the ground
plane and there coordinates are described
in units of metres. Similarly, I can use the
inverse of the homography matrix to go the other way.
So now, I pass in the coordinates of the points on the ground and the result is the set of
image plane coordinates. So, the homography is a really useful tool if I want to map the
coordinates of points between one plane and
another.